How does it feel?
Still going strong.
What's up guys, we are Pongfinity!
Today we are making a racket out of ice.
Let's build it!
So we are using aluminium foil to make the mould.
Something like that...
Okay now it's starting to look good.
Okay now we just pop it out.
Yeah that should work.
Okay so let's pour the water on the mould.
Yeah that's good.
Yeah that's it.
So now we just wait for it to freeze.
Yeah!
That's frozen solid.
That looks just like a normal racket!
I'm afraid I'm going to break it
It feels so fragile.
I guess we just...
Head in and play with it!
Okay so here we have the racket
And now it's time to do some Instagram challenges.
The racket is melting as we speak
so we have to be really quick when filming this.
So let's start with the easiest challenge!
Around the net!
Oooh that was close!
First one in the can!
How's the racket looking?
Ooh it's dripping!
Nooooo it's starting to melt!
Next challenge next challenge!
Go go go go!
What's the next challenge?
Xu Xin ball catch!
Yeah we have to do higher.
Lets go outside!
I think out here we should have enough space.
The roof isn't a problem anymore.
No, not at all.
No!
This is really difficult.
That was okay!
That was quite good!
The Xu Xin ball catch with an ice racket
It's not melting outside anymore.
He doesn't want to go back inside.
But we have to take him back inside.
Alright! Next one chopping!
Is the racket gonna fly off my hand, or?
Wow! It's super fast!
It's dropping so much water.
Look at those chops.
Come on!
It's possible.
Totally working!
It's just the whole floor is full of water drops
Fast to the next challenge!
Next one: try to get spin with the racket
I don't think this is going to work.
Ghost serve
The racket is shrinking between every shot
Okay forehand
That was just floating over the table!
Forehand topsin!
It's almost like underspin
And the status of the racket
Dropping, dropping, dropping.
It's dropping.
Behind the back and between the legs.
Well... you got in the way Miikka!
Okay so for the next challenge
We are gonna ditch the glove
It's time to melt the racket!
It's quite cold to be honest
It's hard to grip it
It got smaller just like in a second!
I have a feeling I'm gonna loose my grip at some point
It's like all the time flying drops there
I'm trying to melt it as fast as I can!
Quite good to play with this
How does it feel?
Yeah, still going strong
Come on, melt!
It's a lot smaller now
Yeah
You shouldn't have shown it!
"I have a feeling I'm gonna loose my grip at some point"
Well, we could still do some racket sharing with this part!
This is not going to work!
Yes?
It's taking a lot of damage
I think we are pretty much done
Still going strong!
His time has come!
That's all what is left
That used to be a table tennis racket
This is what he left behind
Everything that is left from the ice racket
It's almost like a small heart
Well, now it's a broken heart
Okay guys
Fun challenge
Thanks for all the challenge ideas
Until next time!
Otto you can have half of it
Thank you!
Who can eat it?
Emil you have to eat it too!
Otto is actually enjoying it